what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time i'm
here with paulina while wall street is
trying to get rich restless just trying
to get
our lunch money right don't forget that
block five is now the sponsor of lunch
money go to block five dot com slash
pomp
block five dot com slash pop and earn up
to eight point six percent apy an
interest bearing account
or you can take out a us dollar loan to
get your crypto collateral you can buy
and sell cryptocurrencies on their
exchange or you can get on the wait list
for the bitcoin rewards credit card when
i get that credit card i'm gonna go be
spending all my credit
cause i want bitcoin back not cash back
not airline miles bitcoin rewards credit
card what's up blockbuy.com
sorry guys i just went on a walk it was
a really nice day so i'm kind of sporty
today but i just want to point out
starbucks still has the christmas cups
that is very confusing
somebody somebody told me that uh uh by
drinking starbucks you're killing the
environment
who told you that i made that off go
ahead okay elon
musk says people can now buy a tesla
with a bitcoin
uh tesla last month revealed that i had
bought 1.5 billion dollars worth of
bitcoin
um but now elon musk is saying that you
can buy
tesla's and uh it is using internal and
open source software
so the biggest deal here is not that you
can pay for a tesla with bitcoin
it's that tesla is not going to confirm
no they're not going to convert the
bitcoin to dollars right
they're gonna hold the bitcoin he's
trying to acquire as much bitcoin as
possible
you want to give him a bitcoin great
he'll take it he'll give you a call i
ask a dumb question
yeah why did it take elon so long what
what what
what happened well he's a little busy
you know he's creating reusable rockets
living them on drone ships
there's many people who have started uh
payment companies
some of his colleagues have been uh into
bitcoin for a while so look he's there
no problem it's all good uh the second
thing is that they're actually running
nodes and they're uh
interfacing directly with the network
which is a really really big deal
because basically what he's doing is
he's making it cool
uh to um you know actually accept
bitcoin and then hold the bitcoin not
converted to dollars
sorry police pulled up an article and
then she realized that my
brother's tweet is in the article and
she freaked out
okay so um samuel bankman
freed ftx crypto exchange is reportedly
one vote away from winning a naming
rights deal for the arena of the nba's
miami heat
the deal which is believed to be worth
135 million dollars
is set to be approved on march 26 by my
by the miami-dade county commission what
is happening in miami
are we living in a bitcoin city miami is
the bitcoin city in case anyone was
confused we're going to be paying the
employees
in bitcoin you could be paying your
taxes in bitcoin the city
uh sporting arena is named after
cryptocurrency exchange
i'm telling you miami is the bitcoin
city come join us
next you don't have to now be recruiting
people
bitcoin rewards provider oh lawley
raised five million dollars in new
funding
and what's interesting the investors who
are backing the round include alexis
ohanian 776
776 fund and serena williams is
serena ventures you see husband and wife
team investing from their own funds
i love it alex adelman and the team over
at lolly congratulations
they got all kinds of other people where
casey nestak cody ko noel noel miller
phil defranco all kinds of people so
basically
the lolly plans to continue developing
its mobile app and expand
internationally what is lolly
basically when you go on and you buy
things uh they'll give you cash back
but not cash they'll give you bitcoin
back so let's say you go on to a certain
website yeah you go under a certain
website
uh you buy something maybe that website
pays three percent
uh a cash back but actually you'll get
three percent bitcoin back so it's
pretty cool
by the way um the other day anthony was
on clubhouse and i think this was
started by lawley
there is a room called uh church of
satoshi
oh it was not okay well they were in it
are you sure i'm
pretty sure oh yeah you want to tell
them about it
every sunday let's go to church they
were calling me brother pomp
and and they were literally they have a
a prayer they took like the lord's
prayer and they adopted it the bitcoin
and it is so wild and it's amazing they
literally
uh please everyone bow your heads and
we're going to go ahead and say the
break guys before you freak out it's a
tear it's a joke
it's a joke everyone relax all right
next robin hood
maker of the eponymous stock trading app
has confidentially filed it
with the sec for an initial public
offering the investing
platform and popular cryptocurrency
on-ramp has not yet confirmed its plans
which could change but the gears are
moving
toward a public debut insider stole
bloomberg on tuesday so a couple of
things here
one uh robin hood you can't say it's
confidential filing if you didn't go
tell everybody
because it's not so confidential anymore
they confidentially filed
yes you can no you can't be like our
confidential filing
uh second thing is they confidentially
filed and bloomberg found out about it
okay no no no they announced it on
twitter he literally
the ceo tweeted it and was like we have
confidentially filed
whatever uh so that's dumb two
uh i'm still mad don't get it twisted
gamestop didn't go to zero like everyone
claimed these fools
were out here trying to stop everyone
from trading they weren't long
live wall street because baby ones
there is nuance to what he is saying do
your own there's no nuance
stop trying to screw the little guy
gamestop to the moon what did we talk
about gamestop
what did we talk about bitcoin to the
moon gamestop to the moon
all right silver squeeze
prince harry i've been getting all these
like messages about prince harry
has a new job an executive at a silicon
valley startup
he is apparently the chief impact
officer at betterup which is a mental
health
startup now don't get it twisted
chief impact officer is not an executive
position that is a
made-up title they just wanted him
involved they gave it to him i don't
think he is going to be a working
startup executive
how would you get paid for this i don't
know but i don't know
over under five million dollars in the
better up position wait what'd you say
over under five million dollars a year
you think he got paid does better have
that kind of money
they got they got a prince they got so
much cash they literally got a prince on
their
uh team in the better up position prince
harry is expected to have
input into initiatives including product
strategy decisions and charitable
contributions and advocate publicly on
topics related to mental health
aka it's not a real job according to the
ceo it's a
meaningful and meaty role sure
next um all right it's ask long live the
king
who cares about the prince it's ha it's
long live the queen
uh it's asking for the king it's ask
lunch money time hashtag ask
lm in the comments below guys please we
need some more quality questions
oh wait okay um so here's one
ready from david z hi pomp and pimp my
question is for pomp i'm an i-team
manager is a non at a non-profit
hospital and i'd like to present a new
revenue stream for the hospital that
frankly has nothing to do with patient
care
how would you pitch an older generation
of leaders on utilizing some of our
server room space to mine bitcoin
fyi these leaders likely have very
little crypt of knowledge so education
would definitely
be a key role in getting them on board
uh it's very simple
we have computing power that computing
power
goes unmonetized in certain situations
there is a persistent customer that will
pay us
incredibly well for our computing power
we should consider
taking computing power that is not
currently being used
for productive or revenue generating
purposes
and we should redirect it to this other
customer
that will pay us in order to uh leverage
our computing power
and so there's persistent demand for
computing power if you have computing
power that's not being monetized
not being monetized to its fullest
capacity you should consider
lending it to the bitcoin network that's
how i think about it
next voice so this is day 29 today
uh i usually catch my typos i can't
believe i let one slip by
kanye is simply the goat and i won't let
you say otherwise pomp
the first time i ever skipped school was
to go swim in a river with a bunch of
classmates
that was a good day also to my friend
levi i know you believe me but i'm
adding this sentence to prove that yes i
am in fact the infamous
moist i love that his buddy was probably
like you ain't moist
yeah how do you skip school to go
somewhere with your classmates it sounds
like y'all just went on a field trip
it doesn't sound like you skipped
anything you just went on a field trip
come on moist and by the way kanye is
amazing but kanye is not the goat if you
think kanye is the goat that we got
problems that might be the first crack
in our relationship
he is though however a multi-billionaire
and everybody needs to put some respect
on multiple billionaires he's worth six
billion dollars
oh yeah all right what is your question
for moist today
moist if you had six billion dollars
what would you do with it
that's a good one all right guys that
that was the most pathetic salute i've
ever seen
all right come on come on end it
end it i'm ending it bye bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block fight
than you are of me
block lies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends